Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Am Wochenende gab es etwas Bemerkenswertes zu sehen. Und zwar wurde in der ersten Spielminute in der 3. Liga nicht gespielt. Wieso? Weshalb? Warum? Diese Fragen beantwortet uns jetzt Daniel Sauer, Vorstandsvorsitzender und Präsident der Würzburger Kickers. Herr Sauer, herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk. Hallo. Schön, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben, mit uns über diesen Protest zu sprechen. Ja, das war ja durchaus bemerkenswert. Wir hatten so ein bisschen den Protest-Spieltag an diesem Wochenende. Die Fans haben in den ersten und zweiten Ligen protestiert. Und die Drittligisten haben die erste Spielminute tatenlos verstreichen lassen. Erklären Sie uns mal, warum eigentlich?
Ja gut, wir sind am Wochenende natürlich unter dem Motto zusammengekommen, dass wir sagen, wir wollen einfach mal eine Minute stillstehen gegen den Stillstand und da ein bisschen auch auf uns aufmerksam machen, weil wir einfach nicht zufrieden waren mit der Nicht-Lösungsfindung, sage ich jetzt mal ganz plakativ, im Bezug auf die Regionalliga-Reform, dass die ad hoc-Arbeitsgruppe da aufgelöst wurde und die Sachen einfach zu den Regionalverbänden weiter delegiert wurden. Wir sind da ja im Sommer bewusst in Vorleistung gegangen und haben da Kompromissbereitschaft gezeigt und die Hand gereicht und haben einen fetten Absteiger praktisch dann mit dem Spiel geworfen, weil wir auch ganz bewusst dieses Nadel-Regionalliga verbessern wollen als Drittligisten. Wir sind da alle durchgegangen durch dieses Nadelöhr und deswegen setzen wir uns da auch ganz bewusst dann auch für die Regionalligisten ein.
Okay, also es geht im Kern darum, wir haben aktuell fünf Regionaligen und da war immer das Problem, es gab eine Aufstiegsrunde. Das heißt, nicht jeder der Meister der Regionaligen war automatisch für die 3. Liga qualifiziert. Dem soll jetzt Abhilfe geschaffen werden. Da war sich dann auch der DFB als Gesamtverband auf der letzten großen Sitzung einig. Das wurde mit großer Mehrheit beschlossen. Und jetzt gibt es da aber, ist dieser Prozess ins Stocken gekommen. Aber sagen Sie mir mal, warum denn so ein plakativer Protest? Das war ja schon etwas bemerkenswert, dass das alle Drittligisten einfach die erste Spielminute verstreichen lassen. Gab es da keine andere Möglichkeit mehr, sich zu äußern? Oder geht es vor allem darum, jetzt Öffentlichkeit für das Thema zu bekommen?
Ja, natürlich geht es da auch darum, Öffentlichkeit dann für das Thema zu bekommen. Das ist ja auch ganz klar dahinter, weil hinter verschlossenen Türen im letzten Jahr oder seit Beginn, seit wir uns da uns geeinigt haben, es einfach auch nicht vorangegangen ist. Es geht ja darum, wie gesagt, dass wir in Vorleistung gegangen sind und bisher ist da einfach nichts passiert. Wir haben dann auch ein bisschen diesen fehlenden Willen zur Lösungsfindung bemängelt und daher gehört da halt auch dann mal so ein Thema dann auf die Agenda und deswegen waren wir uns da als Drittligisten komplett einig, dass wir dieses Mittel dann auch wählen müssen.
Und mit Vorleistung meinen Sie, dass die Drittligisten zugestimmt haben, dass in einer zweijährigen Übergangsphase vier statt drei Absteiger bestehen?
Ja, genau. Also zu Beginn der Geschichte hieß es ja, dass alle Meister aufsteigen wollen, was ja auch von der DFB-Spitze so gewollt war. Und dazu bräuchte man halt vier Regional-Ligen und dazu bräuchte man natürlich dann auch vier Absteiger. Und diese Vorleistung, die haben wir als Drittligisten gegeben. Das ist sicherlich auch nicht selbstverständlich, da diese Kompromissbereitschaft im Vorfeld schon zu sehen. Vielleicht kann man jetzt auch sagen, im Nachhinein ist es ein Fehler, weil wir in Vorleistung gegangen sind und jetzt nichts weiter passiert ist. Aber wir sind da halt einfach auf die Kompromissbereitschaft oder auf die Lösungsbereitschaft dieser Arbeitsgruppe dann eingegangen. Und von daher ist es halt, wie gesagt, jetzt nicht vorangegangen und deswegen müssen wir da auch aufstehen und unsere Meinung dazu kundtun.
Jetzt waren ja die Drittligisten mit Vertretern auch Teil dieser Arbeitsgruppe. Wer war da eigentlich vertreten? Und wie sehen denn eigentlich die Vorschläge der Drittligisten aus, um dieses nicht ganz einfache Problem zu lösen?
Ja, ich denke, diese Arbeitsgruppe wurde besetzt mit DFB-Spitzen, seitlich mit Peter Fremuth als DFB-Vizepräsident, der diese Arbeitsgruppe geleitet hat, der auch da sehr engagiert ist in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Das muss man auch sagen. Und dann waren regionalen Landesverbände dabei. Als Drittliga-Vertreter war Mario Kalnick vom 1. FC Magdeburg dabei und Helmut Sandruck vom KSC. Dann auch ein paar Regionalliga-Vertreter. Es wurde ein Arbeitsauftrag erstellt. Es macht natürlich keinen Sinn, wenn alle Drittligisten irgendeine Lösung präsentieren, sondern dieser Auftrag wurde an dieser Arbeitsgruppe erteilt. Dann ist man halt auseinandergegangen, dass das Thema dann an die Regionalverbände weiter geleitet wird. Da haben wir die Befürchtung, dass es dann einfach versandet. Das ist halt das, was wir definitiv nicht wollen.
Also diese Arbeitsgruppe wurde aufgelöst. Am 14. November war das und keines der diskutierten Modelle fand eine Mehrheit. Sie haben es jetzt schon angesprochen. Es wurde im Prinzip delegiert. Es hieß, dass die Regionalligen Bayern, Nord sowie Nordost, die müssen sich jetzt einfach einigen, aus diesen drei Ligen sollen in irgendeiner Art und Weise zwei werden. Das hört sich nach einer verfahrenen Situation an. Was wäre denn der konstruktive Lösungsvorschlag der Drittligisten?
Wie gesagt, wir hatten diesen Auftrag nicht, da eine Lösung zu finden, sondern den Auftrag hatte die Arbeitsgruppe. Wir würden uns dann vielleicht auch in Zukunft daran beteiligen, wenn wir merken, dass es da nicht vorangeht. Da verschließen wir uns nicht. Wie gesagt, wir sprechen da sehr einheitlich auch in der Dritten Liga und sind da bereit in diese Richtung da auch was zu tun oder auch dann, wenn das der DFB da nicht hinbekommt, dann in diese Richtung Vorschläge vielleicht auch zu kreieren, auch gemeinsam dann mit den Regionalligisten. Von daher, denke ich, sind wir da gerade intern am Besprechen, was da der sinnvollste Weg ist, um da einfach einen Schritt nach vorne zu kommen für den Fußball, für eine gerechte Regelung des Aufstiegs logischerweise auch und nicht um das Thema, was alle eigentlich wollten, dann irgendwie versandten zu lassen.
Jetzt gibt es ja zwei Arten, wie man auf diese Sache gucken kann. Das eine ist so ein bisschen von oben nach unten, also wir gucken von der 3. Liga auf die Regionalliga und das andere ist ja von unten nach oben. Die Regionalligisten gucken auf die 3. Liga. Da gab es jetzt schon viele kritische Kommentare zu dieser Protestaktion und von außen betrachtet könnte man auch sagen, also arg solidarisch sieht das Vorgehen jetzt nicht aus, auch so ein bisschen die Reichweite der Drittligisten dafür zu verwenden, nur auf den einen Standpunkt hinzuweisen in der Öffentlichkeit. Wie würden sie diesem Vorwurf begegnen?
Ja, ich denke, wie gesagt, wir als Drittligisten wissen ja auch, wie dieses Nadelhör ausschaut und wir wissen auch sehr genau, was das bedeutet und da solidarisieren wir uns klar auch mit den Vereinen der Regionalliga, die auch durch diesen Flaschenhals müssen und kämpfen auch für diese Vereine, werden auch mit den Vereinen einfach Kontakt aufnehmen, was wir da gemeinsam für eine Lösung kreieren können und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die Vereine ja da alle das kritisch begegnen. Natürlich gab es ein paar kritische Stimmen in dieser Richtung, aber es gab auch ein paar wie die Babelsberger zum Beispiel, die da auch ganz klar öffentlich Position bezogen haben und von daher, ja, nehmen wir das dann auch gerne in die Hand, wenn, wie gesagt, wenn das beim DFB dann nicht funktioniert.
Es scheint eine sehr gute Organisation der Entscheidungsträger in der Dritten Liga zu geben, gab es denn mal Überlegungen, gemeinsam mit den Regionalligisten auf diesen Umstand hinzuweisen? Denn eigentlich, Sie haben es ja jetzt mehrfach angesprochen, sitzen ja alle im gleichen Boot, man ist ja nicht davor gefeiert, dass man mal absteigt und dann sitzt man wieder vor diesem Flaschenhals.
Ja, natürlich. Also, ich meine, es waren ja auch in dieser Arbeitsgruppe Regionalliga-Vertreter dabei oder Landesverbandsvertreter auch dabei, aber da, wie gesagt, wurde es dann halt irgendwie in einer gewissen Art und Weise so gesteuert, dass, wie gesagt, dieser klare Wille da nicht vorhanden war. Und daher sind wir damit einfach unzufrieden, wie das gelaufen ist und viele Regionalligisten dann schon auch.
Ja, wo war denn dann dieser Wille nicht vorhanden? Auf Seiten des DFB? Das hört sich jetzt immer so ein bisschen an, als ob eigentlich die –Front ist jetzt vielleicht ein zu hartes Wort, aber die Meinungsverschiedenheiten zwischen den Vereinen und den DFB-Gremien verlaufen würden. Welche Rolle spielen denn da die Verbände zum Beispiel?
Ja, also grundsätzlich hat man ja auch darüber gesprochen, dass wir auch Herr Grindel und Herr Koch gesagt haben, okay, der Meister muss aufsteigen, das war so das Grundprinzip, aufgrund dessen wir dann auch zusammengekommen sind und dann diesen vierten Absteiger zugestimmt haben. Auch dann auf dem Bundestag, auf dem die Drittligisten ja keine Stimme haben, wenn man da über den Demokratieverständnis spricht, dann ist das natürlich auch was, wo die Drittligisten ganz klar in Zukunft auch eine statuarische Verankerung brauchen.
Damit gehen sie darauf an, dass Reinhard Grindel den Drittligisten vorgeworfen hätte, sie würden ein sehr fragwürdiges Demokratieverständnis ausleben.
Ja, ein sehr fragwürdiges Demokratieverständnis, ja genau. Also klar, dieses Zitat, das kann man sicherlich mal herausnehmen, weil in meinen Augen auch eine gewisse Art Diskussion oder Protest oder Streik zu einem Demokratieverständnis auch dazugehört. Und was ihr eben auch gerade schon gesagt habt, dass man eben auch in der Demokratie eine Stimme braucht, um gestalten zu können, das haben wir im Moment nicht. Und deswegen muss man das auch klar mal hinterfragen, was da in den Raum geworfen wurde.
Jetzt würde mich mal noch ein bisschen das etwas breitere Bild interessieren. Das alles ist nachvollziehbar, dass man nicht absteigen möchte. Gleichzeitig ist nachvollziehbar, dass die Regionalligisten auch auf eine Lösung des Problems beharren, dass eben der meiste nicht automatisch aufsteigt. Da gab es einige sportliche Dramen in den letzten Jahren. Jetzt hat man ja aber schon immer wieder gehört, dass die Situation der Drittligisten nicht allzu rosig ist. Können Sie mal gerade so beschreiben, was sind so die größten Probleme, mit denen Sie sich jetzt bei den Würzburger Kickers und auch bei anderen Vereinen herumschlagen müssen? Und dann ist ja diese Abstiegsregelung wahrscheinlich nur eins von vielen.
Ja, und deswegen muss man auch sagen, das ist ja eine hohe Kompromissbereitschaft, die wir als Drittligisten da einfach auch in den Raum geworfen werden. Wir haben die Abstiegsregelung verschärft. Das führt natürlich zwangsläufig zu einem Wettrüsten, was natürlich dann auch verschiedene Kosten, Kaderkosten oder sonstige Kosten dann einfach auch erhöht, um konkurrenzfähig zu bleiben. Also von daher ist es schon ein großes Brett, das wir da in den Raum gestellt haben. Aber auf der anderen Seite erwarten wir natürlich auch, dass dann da mit diesem Pfand, das wir da in die Mitte gelegt haben, dass damit auch vernünftig umgegangen wird und das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass wir einfach sagen, okay, ob jetzt drei oder vier Absteiger, das ist egal. Also irgendeinen wird es als vierten dieses Jahr treffen, das ist unumstritten. Und das, wie gesagt, geht halt dann nicht auf Kosten der dritten Liga. Und dass wir auch auf andere Themen, um die Professionalisierung und die Weiterentwicklung der dritten Liga voranzutreiben, das wird auch andere Sachen brauchen, wie die Erhöhung von Vermarktungserlösen zum Beispiel, um da überhaupt vernünftig wirtschaften zu können. Das ist ja unbestritten und da geben die Drittliga-Kollegen um Manuel Hartmann auch, gehen da in kleinen Schritten auch voran und entwickeln das auch weiter und man muss ja auch sagen, die eingleisige dritte Liga hat sich zu einer Top-Liga entwickelt. Wir sprechen da immer von der attraktivsten und stärksten dritten Liga aller Zeiten, Zuschauer stärkste Liga aller Zeiten und da sind Top-Vereine in der Liga und wie gesagt, das muss man eben konsequent weiter professionalisieren.
Und was würde im Falle eines Abstiegs in die Regionalliga drohen? Vielleicht können Sie es mal am Beispiel der Kickers durchexerzieren, ohne dass das jetzt eine Bewertung der sportlichen Lage sein soll. Da sieht es ja gerade wieder ein bisschen besser aus nach dem Spieltag am Wochenende. Aber was bedeutet es denn für ein Drittligisten, wenn man in die Regionalliga absteigt?
Ja, die dritte Liga ist die erste Profiliga, die es gibt. Das heißt, wenn man in die Regionalliga wieder zurückgeht, dann ist man erstmal wieder nicht im Profibereich. Und natürlich denken wir auch daran, dass wir uns dann stark machen für eine faire und transparente Aufstiegsregelung. Und das ist eben so, wenn es dann vier Regionalligen gäbe, was der klare Auftrag war, dann gibt es auf der anderen Seite eben auch vier Aufsteiger, was es natürlich dann auch wieder leichter macht, zumindest nicht auf zwei Spiele in Relegationsspielen dann darauf ankommt, sondern auf eine konstante Performance in der ganzen Liga über die ganze Saison hinweg, was dann auch einfach den Weg nach oben wieder ein bisschen leichter macht. Sowohl für denjenigen, der dann vielleicht absteigt, wie auch für andere Vereine.
Und kann man das finanziell irgendwie beziffern, den Unterschied zwischen Profifußball und Regionalliga?
Wie groß ist da der Cut?
Der Cut ist natürlich nicht ganz so groß, wie wenn man von der 2. Liga in die 3. Liga absteigt, das ist auch klar. Aber auf der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt ja schon einfach ein paar Vermarktungserlöse oder Zentralvermarktung oder CV-Gelder, die wir in der 3. Liga haben, die halt dann auf Null reduziert werden. Und das ist natürlich dann schon noch mal eine ganz andere Hausnummer, diesen Neuanfang dann wieder zu starten und zu passieren.
Jetzt haben sich schon einige obere des DFB geäußert, also über Reinhard Grindel haben wir schon kurz gesprochen. Auch der DFB-Vizepräsident und Vorsitzende des Bayerischen Fußballverbandes Rainer Koch hat sich gemeldet und hat unter anderem gesagt, wäre die 3. Liga zweigleisig, hätten wir eine echte pyromedale Ligenstruktur. Und mit Bildung, der dann fünf oder sogar sechs Regionalligen überhaupt keine Probleme. Da haben sie vorhin schon ein bisschen drauf Bezug genommen, indem sie die Eingleisigkeit der 3. Liga hervorgehoben haben. Was wäre denn so schlimm daran, eine zweite, dritte Liga nebendran zu stellen? Man könnte das ja regional ganz gut auch teilen und damit würden ja auch einige Kosten hinsichtlich Reisen wegfallen.
Ja, es würden aber auch einige Einnahmen dann auf mehr Vereine aufgeteilt werden, wo man jetzt wie gesagt in den letzten Jahren ja schon ein paar Schritte in die richtige Richtung gemacht hat. Das ist klar, dass da noch größere Schritte gemacht werden müssen. Aber ich glaube, dass eine Vermarktung einer Profiliga, so wie es jetzt eben in den letzten zehn Jahren entwickelt wurde, dass diese eingleisige Form sich einfach bewahrt hat und dass man jetzt einfach noch auf Einnahmenseite weiter nach vorne kommen muss. Alle gemeinsam und ich denke, wie gesagt, die Attraktivität mit den Traditionsmannschaften und den ambitionierten Mannschaften und auch teilweise den Mannschaften, die aus der Regionalliga nach oben drängen, da ist man auf dem richtigen Weg und von daher ist aus unserer Sicht ganz klar einhellig die Meinung, dass eine eingleisige Form der 3. Liga einfach alternativlos ist.
Das hört sich jetzt für mich so ein bisschen an, als ob man zu einer Lösung nur kommen könnte. Also es wird ein Kompromiss werden, der allen Beteiligten irgendwie ein bisschen wehtun wird. Es wird irgendwo zwicken. Aber gleichzeitig hängt da noch so eine finanzielle Komponente mit dran. Wäre es denn aus Ihrer persönlichen Sicht heraus ein gangbarer Weg, dass man sagt, ja, wir bleiben bei der eingleisigen 3. Liga und dann muss die Regionalliga, die Regionalligen müssen für sich eine Lösung finden. Aber weil da dann ja auch wieder Mannschaften benachteiligt werden, man versucht das finanziell ein bisschen aufzufangen, indem man ein bisschen Einnahmen umverteilt. Und dann, ich sage es jetzt, den Regionalligen den Schmerz etwas lindert durch finanzielle Zuwendung. Wäre das eine Möglichkeit?
Na gut, dann müsste man halt irgendwo einen neuen Topf aufmachen, weil, wie gesagt, die Kapitalausstattung der Drittligisten, die ist im Moment einfach nicht ausreichend und dann von einer nicht ausreichenden Ausstattung einfach noch was abzugeben, ist natürlich dann ein bisschen schwierig, so gern wir das machen würden. Aber ich denke, da ist es eher so, dass man dann noch einen zusätzlichen Topf einfach aufmachen müsste und dann versuchen müsste, das Thema auch nach vorne zu bringen.
Kann es vielleicht sein, dass das so ein bisschen das grundlegende Problem im deutschen Profifußball Schrägstrich Amateurfußball ist, dass einfach die erste Liga und die zweite Liga in Teilen noch den wesentlichen Teil aller Einnahmen für sich nutzen können und die finanzielle Versorgung nach unten hin immer mehr ausdünnt und wir das vielleicht an solchen Konflikten dann auch erleben, wo dann die beteiligten Vereine konsequenterweise erst mal auf sich gucken und nicht gleich im Solidaritätsgedanken aufgehen können?
Ja, man muss natürlich auch ein Kompliment an die DFL machen, wie sie die Themen vermarktet, was man da auch an Erlössteigerungen hat. Also die DFL hat da super Konzepte und hat da tolle Leute, die das dann auch umsetzen und die Erlöse dann auch generieren und von daher, glaube ich, kann man sich da auch sicherlich die eine oder andere Scheibe abschneiden. Und wie gesagt, man ist ja da, man hat ja da prozentual Steigerungen, aber man muss die halt noch weiter forcieren und da wäre halt eine zweigleisige Drittliga einfach wieder ein Rückschritt, weil sie einfach an Adressivität verlieren würde.
Aber man muss natürlich auch irgendwas tun für die Regionalligen, wenn die von 5 auf 4 verdünnen, dann werden ja auch wieder. Da werden dann Mannschaften nicht mehr zum zukommen, die jetzt eine Möglichkeit haben und dass die Problematik, dass dann es keine TV-Einnahmen mehr gibt und man das dann irgendwie über Sponsoring-Erlöse auffangen müsste und gleichzeitig ja aber auch durch die Fehlen der TV-Präsenz, da weniger attraktiv ist für mögliche Unternehmen, die ist ja nicht wegzudiskutieren.
Ja, ich denke, die Sponsoring-Erlöse, da ist jeder Verein natürlich dann auch für sich selbst in seiner Region verantwortlich. Also da muss man schauen, dass man seine Marke oder seinen Verein so weit wie möglich voranbringt, Alleinstellungsmerkmale kreiert, um eben Attraktivität für Unternehmen zu bekommen. Da ist jeder, denke ich, natürlich für sich selber verantwortlich, aber in einer Zentralvermarktung, da ist dann eben die Liga interessant und ich denke, im Moment hat man eine Aufstiegsregelung, die jeder Spezialist erst auf den dritten Blick sieht. Also da war ja die davor fast noch ein bisschen einfacher. Und das ist natürlich nur eine Übergangslösung, ganz klar, und von daher muss man da einfach auch ein bisschen Transparenz wieder reinbekommen.
Jetzt findet in wenigen Tagen am 7. Dezember die nächste DFB-Präsidiumssitzung statt. Ist es Zufall, dass der Protest vor dieser Präsidiumssitzung stattgefunden hat?
Ja gut, dass das Thema dort diskutiert wird, auch ohne den Protest, das ist, denke ich, klar.
Aber jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen anders.
Ich denke, es war eher eine zeitliche Abhängigkeit zu der Auflösung der Arbeitsgruppe oder zu der Weiterdelegation der Arbeitsgruppe, sodass wir einfach da darauf reagieren mussten, mit diesem Ergebnis, wo wir einfach nicht zufrieden waren.
Und könnten Sie mir jetzt ein konkretes Wunschszenario aufmachen? Was würden Sie sich wünschen als Lösung für dieses Problem der Aufstiegsregelung in die 3. Liga?
Ja, dass wir einfach eine klare Aufstiegsregelung haben. Der Grundgedanke und die Grundidee, die Grundintention war, dass der Meister aufsteigen muss. Wie gesagt, dafür haben wir einen vierten Absteiger in den Raum geschmissen, sonst wäre das gar nicht möglich, da überhaupt einen Kompromiss zu finden. Dann ist es natürlich ganz klar, dass wir dann, um eine transparente Lösung zu haben, dass die Meister aus den vier Regionalligen dann direkt in die 3. Liga aufsteigen. So hat einfach jeder Verein Planbarkeit. Wir haben das ja selber auch erlebt, haben eine überragende Saison in der Regionalliga gespielt und am Ende hängt es an einem Elfmeterschießen und da kann man erst dann in der letzten Sekunde das Thema planen, was natürlich auch für die Vereine sehr, sehr schwierig macht. Und von daher ist sowas einfach der einzig mögliche Kompromiss zwischen der 3. Liga und den Regionalligisten und da müssen wir gemeinsam an den Tisch, um da voranzukommen und das Thema nicht versanden zu lassen.
Okay, also dann würde ich das so zusammenfassen. Die Drittligisten haben dadurch, dass sie schon einen zusätzlichen Absteiger zugestimmt haben, ihren Schritt getan und sie sehen die Lösung des Problems jetzt bei den Regionalligen.
Nein, ich denke, für eine Problemlösung brauchen wir immer alle Parteien, die am Tisch sind. Also ich sage ja auch ganz klar, dass wir mit den Regionalligisten solidarisieren, dass wir für die Regionalligisten auch einstehen und kämpfen. Weil für die Regionalligisten ist es natürlich auch eine schwierige Situation, wenn sie keine Planbarkeit haben und von daher ist es ja auch wichtig für die Regionalligisten, dass sie eine klare Aufstiegsregelung haben und von daher muss man da gemeinsam an den Tisch. Und wie gesagt, wer dann jetzt in Zukunft dafür zuständig ist, ich glaube halt nicht, dass es aktuell bei den Regionalverbänden weiter vorangetrieben wird. Dafür war die Arbeitsgruppe eingerichtet und die hat es dann weitergegeben. Und damit sind wir einfach nicht zufrieden und da muss einfach was passieren.
Ich glaube, das haben wir jetzt ganz gut rausgearbeitet. Und die Neuregelung des Aufstiegs soll Ende September 2019 verabschiedet werden, auf dem dann stattzufindenden DFB-Bundestag. Das heißt, ein bisschen Zeit ist noch, aber jetzt glaube ich, nach dem Aufdrösen dieser Problematik sieht man arg so viel Zeit ist es dann vielleicht doch nicht. Es ist ein komplexes Thema. Herr Sauer, ich danke Ihnen sehr, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben und bin mal sehr gespannt, wie man da zu einer Lösung kommen wird. Es ist eine verfahrene Situation von allen Seiten, wenn Sie mich fragen. Danke Ihnen für Ihre Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über Spenden. Das heißt, wenn ihr uns unterstützen wollt, geht doch mal auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützenda, erfahrt ihr alles weitere dazu. Und ansonsten hören wir uns nach dem nächsten Bundesligaspieltag und sprechen dann über den 14. Spieltag. Bis dahin, macht's gut, eine gute Woche euch, ciao.